si votre fille rend pas chez vous et
vous disait papa je voudrais poser un
noir est ce que ça vous gênerait
vraiment ça ne paierait pas du tout
maintenant si c'était son désir jal sfr
doit peut-être peut-être je dirais non
non je n'aurais pas envisager parce que
je crois qu'il ne faut pas mêler les
races j'estime que chacun se doit rester
entre elles je crois que le métis n'est
pas une chose à souhaiter avec ce serait
pour leur malheur je le crois qu'est ce
que vous lui diriez pas je lui dirai que
il ya des blancs quand même sur la terre
chez pai nous sommes ce soit quelque
chose auprès des amis auprès des parents
yachting jeune fille qui se mariait
gallois mais il me semble que
après tout après les avoir connus ces
gens là peut-être mon fils sont des gens
très bien quoi est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que vous êtes ce qu'on
appelle raciste pas tout à fait non mais
j'estime que chacun doit rester à sa
place